AND POLICE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
HELPING KEEP THAT FLORIDA
SHOOTING SUSPECT UNDER THE
RADAR.
BUT WE BEGIN WITH THE NUMBER
OF FAST MOVING DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE RUSSIA PROBE.
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE MEMBER
TOM ROUHANI TOLD FOX NEWS
TODAY THAT THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION HAS BECOME A
DEAD END AFTER TESTIMONY BY
WHITE HOUSE AIDE HOPE HICKS.
WELL THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS BEEN INSISTING
WITH NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION HAVING BEEN
EMERGED.
AND NOW THERE ARE NEW
CHARGES FROM DEVIN NUNES
THAT THE FBI MAY HAVE
VIOLATED FEDERAL LAW IN
SEEKING THAT FISA WARRANT
AND, THERE MAY BE MORE
INDICTMENTS COMING FROM THE
MUELLER TEAM OF MORE
RUSSIANS.
THIS TO MY KNOWLEDGE FOR THE
HACKING.
TO GET INTO IT ALL, LET'S
BRING IN FORMER DEPUTY
INDEPENDENT COUNCIL SAUL
WISENBURG, SAN FRANCISCO
ATTORNEY AND RNC COMMITTEE
WOMAN FROM CALIFORNIA
HARMEET DHILLON AND
WASHINGTON ATTORNEY AND
CHAIR OF THE D.C. DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SCOTT BOLD DEN.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
WE HAVE A LOT OF NEWS TO GET
THROUGH TONIGHT.
TOM REASON J ON
TOM ROOSON J ON
TOM ROONEN J ON
TOM ROONEY,J ON
TOM ROONEY, ION
TOM ROONEY, I DON'T THINK HE
HAS GIVEN ONE INTERVIEW
ABOUT THE PROBE YET.
HE SAID TODAY ON THE HOUSE
INTEL SIDE, HE SAID THIS
THING SHOULD WRAP UP FROM
WHAT HE HAS SEEN BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS, THERE IS NO
COLLUSION.
THEY HAVE SEEN NO EVIDENCE
OF THAT.
AND HE SAID, YOU KNOW, THIS
THING -- WE SHOULD END THIS
THING.
ON THE MUELLER THING, HE
SAID, WELL, THAT HAS TO KEEP
GOING.
I'M NOT GOING TO SPEAK TO
THAT.
BUT HE WAS REALLY ADAMANT.
SAUL, GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW
NOW, WHAT THE FOCUS IS OF
THIS INVESTIGATION, WHAT ARE
THE KEY POINTS?
>> KEY POINTS ARE WAITING
FOR BOB MUELLER AND WE JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE HAS KEPT A VERY TIGHT,
TIGHT SHIP OVER THERE.
I'M NOT AT ALL SURPRISED BY
THE REPORT OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND ALSO YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER, HOWEVER, A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE IN
TO TESTIFY HAVE REFUSED TO
DO SO.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
POWER ANYWHERE NEAR THE
POWER THAT BOB MUELLER HAS.
NOW, HAVING SAID THAT WHAT
WE DO KNOW PUBLICLY RIGHT
NOW, INCLUDING WHAT PEOPLE
HAVE SAID ABOUT HOW THEY
WERE QUESTIONED BY MUELLER
IS THAT WE STILL DON'T HAVE
ON THE PUBLIC RECORD ANY
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BY
TRUMP OR PEOPLE CLOSELY
AFFILIATED WITH TRUMP.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS.
YOU HAVE -- YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF STUFF ABOUT
PAPADOPOULOS BUT IS HE A
VERY MINOR FIGURE.
>> Laura: LET'S GET TO
ANDREW MCCABE, SCOTT, LET'S
GO TO YOU ON THIS.
ANDREW MCCABE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI IS NOW
IT LOOKS LIKE THE I.G. IS
GOING TO COME DOWN ON HIM
HARD BECAUSE HE DIRECTED FBI
STAFF TO SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION OCTOBER 2016
WITH THE MEDIA.
>> WELL, HE MAY HAVE SHARED
IT HIMSELF.
I MEAN, THEY WANTED TO GIVE
SOME INFORMATION OUT TO THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND THEY
ACTUALLY SET IT UP.
THE PR PEOPLE AT THE FBI.
IF YOU MADE A BAD JUDGMENT
CALL AND USED THAT
INFORMATION THAT WAS
CONFIDENTIAL WHEN HE SHARED
IT TO KIND OF BALANCE OUT
THE ARTICLE, THEN CERTAINLY
HE IS GOING TO BE
DISCIPLINED BUT THE REALITY
IS, ANDREW MCCABE IS A
REPUBLICAN, ONE, AND TWO, IN
THAT ARTICLE, HE WAS ARGUING
FOR THE FBI TO CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE HRC.
>> Laura: THERE IS A DISPUTE
ABOUT THAT.
TWO DIFFERENT ACCOUNTS.
I THINK THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
LAYS IT OUT.
TWO DIFFERENT ACCOUNTS.
SOME SAY HE ACTUALLY WANTED
THE HILLARY INVESTIGATION
NOT TO GO FORWARD.
AND THEN HIS HAVING CHAMPION
SAY NO, NO, NO, FBI CAN YOU
DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
SENIOR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS DISAGREE.
>> I DO MET PARTICULAR TRILY
OPPOSED POSITIONS.
FACTS DON'T LIKE AND THEY
DON'T GO AWAY REPUBLICANS
SCREW THINGS UP ALL THE
TIME.
>> WHY ARE REPUBLICANS
OBSESSED WITH ANDREW MCCABE.
>> Laura: ANDREW MCCABE IS
BEST BUDS WITH JIM COMEY.
BUT HE WAS THE LEAD IN THE
HILLARY EMAIL INVESTIGATION
AND TOOK A LEAD IN THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AND IF YOU ARE PUSHING
STORIES TO THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" IN OCTOBER 2016 IN
ADDITION TO THE CONCERNS
ABOUT HIS WIFE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, YOU CAN'T
BLAME DONALD TRUMP THINKING
THIS GUY SHOULD NEVER HAVE
BEEN TOUCHING MY CASE.
EVEN JUST GIVEN HIS WIFE'S
CONNECTION TO TERRY
MCAULIFF.
HARMEET?
>> ABSOLUTELY, LAURA, WHAT
WE ARE SEEING HERE IS ONE
MORE BRUSH STROKE IN A
PAINTING.
ALL OF THESE STROKES ARE
COMING TOGETHER TO SHOW
THERE WAS AN ENTIRE CULTURE
AT THE FBI AND EVEN, YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THE ACTIONS
THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN WITH
REGARD TO THE FISA COURT
SHOW COMPLETE LACK OF REGARD
FOR THE ETHICS RULES THAT
WOULD APPLY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE MAKING
FALSE REPRESENTATIONS TO A
COURT.
SO NOTHING THAT IS COMING
OUT HERE WITH REGARD TO
MCCABE OR ANY OF THESE OTHER
PLAYERS IS SURPRISING TO ME.
IT'S JUST SURPRISING THAT
THEY ARE BEING ALLOWED TO
YOU GET AWAY WITH IT AND
DISTRACT ALL OF US FROM WHAT
SHOULD BE GOING ON AND THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON IN THE COUNTRY MOVING
FORWARD.
THEY HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
BOGGING HIM DOWN.
THAT'S A PART OF THIS.
>> Laura: KEN STARR, SAUL
SAID TODAY ABOUT THE SCOPE
OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE HEARING STUFF ABOUT
JARED KUSHNER.
HEARING THINGS ABOUT IVANKA
TRUMP NOW.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> I THINK IT'S BEYOND HIS
MANDATE.
THE MANDATE IS WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION IN
TERMS OF COLLUSION.
THAT'S THE KEY IDEA.
SO, HERE'S WHAT I THINK IS
HAPPENING I THINK BOB
MUELLER IS FINDINGS OUT
INFORMATION LEADING HIM BACK
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Laura: SAUL YOU, YOUR
COMMENTS ON THAT?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
IT'S OUTSIDE THE MANDATE IN
TERMS OF THE SPECIFIC ITEMS
COVERED.
BUT, REMEMBER, THE MANDATE
SAYS IF THERE'S ANYTHING --
ANY CRIME THAT DIRECTLY
ARISES FROM THE
INVESTIGATION, HE CAN LOOK
AT IT WE KNOW FROM ROD
ROSENSTEIN'S TESTIMONY THAT
HE HAS GOT TO GO TO ROD
ROSENSTEIN IF ANY OF THOSE
THINGS OCCUR AND HE HAS GOT
TO GET THE IMREEMENT OF
ROSENSTEIN.
SO THE REAL STORY HERE.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
DOUBT HE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
AUTHORIZATION.  THE STORY IS
WE KNOW FROM THE MANAFORT
INDICTMENT AND THE GATES
INDICTMENT ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO IS LOOK AT IT.
THEN HE GOT AUTHORIZATION
LONG AGO TO GO BEYOND THE
FOUR CORN
FOUR CONNERS AT LEAST THE
SPECIFIC THINGS IS HE
SUPPOSED TO LOOKING AT.
I'M SURPRISED IT HASN'T BEEN
COMMENTED ON THAT.
EARLIER.
IF I CAN GO BACK TO MCCABE,
TO ME THE TWO MAIN THINGS
ABOUT MCCABE THAT WE HAVE
DEEP GOING BACK TO, ONE, OUT
GROSS CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN EITHER THE EMAIL
OR THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION, WHICH, IF YOU
BELIEVE NEWS REPORTS, HE
KEPT AGENCIES FROM LOOKING -- AE
KEPT AGENCIES FROM LOOKING -- AT
KEPT AGENCIES FROM LOOKING -- AS
KEPT AGENCIES FROM LOOKING -- AF
KEPT AGENCIES FROM LOOKING -- AO
KEPT AGENCIES FROM LOOKING -- AM
LOOKING AT THINGS.
NUMBER TWO HE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT FISA WARRANT.
AND THAT FISA WARRANT HE HAS
ADMITTED AND THE SHIFT MEMO
DID NOT CONTRADICT THIS.
IF THEY HAD NOT HAD THE
STEEL DOSSIER.
THEY WOODLAND NOT HAVE EVEN
SUBMITTED THAT.  THAT'S A
SHOCKING THING THAT FISA
WARRANT.
>> Laura: IN THE DEVIN NUNES
WENT CHAPTERS AND VERSE
ABOUT THE DOJ GUIDELINES, IN
PART THE ACCURACY OF
INFORMATION CONTAINED WITHIN
FISA APPLICATIONS IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE.
ONLY DOCUMENTED AND VERIFIED
INFORMATION MAY BE USED TO
YOU SUPPORT FBI
APPLICATIONS, FISA, TO THE
FISA COURT.
THEY DID NOT VERIFY THE
OUTRAGEOUS ALLEGATIONS IN
THIS DOSSIER AND THEY
COULDN'T.
THERE WAS NO WAY FOR THEM
TO, YET THAT WAS AT THE CORE
OF THIS APPLICATION.
WAS A FEDERAL STATUTE
VIOLATED IN THEIR SUBMISSION
OF THIS FISA APPLICATION.
>> WE WILL CERTAINLY NEVER
KNOW THAT IT SEEMS TO ME ET
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS THINK IT WAS THE
HEART OF THAT FISA WARRANT
AND THE DEMOCRATS THINK IT
WAS PART OF IT.
WE KNOW BACK IN SEPTEMBER OF
016 THAT THE INTEL AGENCIES
WERE PICKING UP THESE
COMMUNICATIONS AND DOING
THEIR OWN INVESTIGATION.
IF YOU DIDN'T VERIFY
EVERYTHINGED IN THE FISA
WARRANT, IF YOU DIDN'T
DOCUMENT EVERYTHING, THAT
MEANS THERE WERE OTHER
THINGS IN THAT FISA WARRANT
THAT TOLD YOU THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OR THE
CAMPAIGN NEEDED TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
AND BY THE WAY, THERE IS A
TERM CALLED CROCTION
TERM CALLED CORCTION
TERM CALLED CORROION
TERM CALLED CORROBON
TERM CALLED CORROBORATION
THAT SOLVE KNOWS VERY WELL.
IF EVERYTHING WAS
CORROBORATED, WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT THEN.
YOU MAKE A BIG TEAL OUT OF
THIS FISA WARRANT.
THEY WON'T BACK TO THE FISA
JUDGES THREE OR FOUR TIMES
I.
>> WHAT DOES IT HAVE TO DO
WITH DONALD TRUMP, WHY DID
FOUR JUDGES DO IT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN?
LAWYERS LAWYERS BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T POLLED.
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER.
>> EVEN IF THEY DID.
>> Laura: SOLVE, LET'S GET
DOWN TO BRASS TACKS HERE OR
OR HARMEET.
DO YOU THINK THAT A FEDERAL
JUDGEN THE FISA COURT IF HE
KNEW WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS
DOSSIER AND WHO PAID FOR IT
THAT THEY WOULD NOT AT LEAST
GONE BACK AND SAID DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING ELSE?
THIS SEEMS LIKE A DLECKET
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
GO AHEAD, SOLVE.
>> THEY WOULD HAVE
ABSOLUTELY ASKED FURTHER
QUESTIONS.
SCOTT MAKES ONE FAIR POINT.
>> FAIR POINT NOT A GOOD
POINT.
>> LET ME COMPLIMENT YOU,
WHEN THEY GO BACK THREE
TIMES THEY HAVE TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF INFORMATION ABOUT
PAGE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE FACT,
AND THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE
AREN'T PICKING UP ON WITH
EXCEPTION OF A COUPLE OF
WRITERS LIKE ANDREW
MCCARTHY.
STEELE HIMSELF DO HAVE BEEN
THE MOST CREDIBLE PERSON IN
THE WORLD.
BUT ALMOST ALL OF HIS
INFORMATION WAS COMPLETELY,
I MEAN COMPLETELY
UNVERIFIED.
THAT'S SHOCKING AND ACTUALLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THE FISA
JUDGES SHOULD HAVE TO APE
FOR SOME DAY OR EXPLAIN.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR ABOUT
THAT.
I DON'T CARE WHETHER THEY
ARE REPUBLICANS OR VOTED FOR
HAROLD SASSENS OR WHAT?
>> I WAS GOING TO AGREE THAT
THE MISREPRESENTATIONS FOR
THE FISA COURTS CANNOT BE
MINIMIZED HERE.
THEY ARE CRITICAL AND
CENTRAL TO THE ISSUANCE YOU
HAVE THIS WARRANT OVER
SINGLE TIME AND WHETHERTH
FISA IS OPEN TO ABUSES LIKE
THIS.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS
IMPORTANT IS WHAT DIFFERENT
NUNES.
IT NOT JUST LYING TO THE
FISA COURT.
OBSTRUCTION YOU HAVE
JUSTICE.
CONSPIRACY TO VIOLATE THE
RIGHTS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
THAT'S SILLY.
>> NONE OF IT IS PROVEN.
>> THANKS, GUYS.
THERE IS A BULLET.
THERE IS A BULLET YOU HAD
SERIES OF VIOLATIONS THAT HE
SAYS ARE POTENTIAL.
I THINK THE ONE THAT IS
PROTESTY ON YUX IS
GUIDELINES.
PHENOMENAL PANEL AND I CAN'T
BELIEVE SOL COMPLIMENTED
SCOTT.
THAT -- THAT'S NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> WINS A MONTH.
ONCE A MONTH.